two biggest things that differentiate
this brand zoo culture from like all
these other gyms
is is obviously the community and the
actual connection
and the culture within it yeah and then
the actual equipment right because i the
craziest thing i said this before i
opened the gym i said i knew this gym
would be successful even if it wasn't me
doing it because
over the course of like five years on
social media
i along with many other like fitness
influencers like posted so much content
over the years we're like
you're 24 hour fitness or you're la
fitness or whatever jim
like i would go to random places because
that was my whole life go to film
content at gyms to like go
film like lifting this crazy heavy
dumbbell at this gym and like you kipo's
like a 375 pound dumbbell or
going to this gym traveling this gym
going all over the place and the
internet would see
that content be like this equipment or
like that dumbbell or like this type of
barbell or like that type of machine and
they'd be like what is this what like
imagine how many dm's over the years
like where the [ __ ] is this
yeah so that would actually drive sales
for these yeah so like
most gyms don't have any of that stuff
right and imagine over four or five
years six years you have people being
like man i want to do this i want to try
this yeah so i knew like even before i
opened the gym i was like this kind of
gym that involved like
crossfit power team bodybuilding like
obviously i need a bigger space i wish i
had more
more equipment but having all that stuff
that people haven't seen over the years
are like you know the
chains and like the different types of
attachments yeah the the
kettlebells like the the whole like
that's not that's not a normal
kettlebells are now
but it's not like a normal gym thing so
you see this over time
and not just me like i said all the
other influencers in fitness and you're
like oh [ __ ] like where is that and then
imagine someone opens a gym where like
you know that it's there
yeah so you want to show up yeah right
beyond like the whole like
social media celebrity type thing where
someone wants to come visit me i just
knew that kind of gym would do well
yeah you attract serious people who know
what they're doing and so here's another
thing
on that same thing with community but
also the equipment imagine
my goal was like i want to open up near
every 24-hour fitness or la fitness or
gold gym it didn't matter it wasn't
competition because i knew that there'd
be people in those gyms that are just a
little more serious yeah and that that
would be the crowd that'd be like
[ __ ] this [ __ ] this place i want to go
there yeah because you know you know
like
if you've been a 24 hour finish if
you've ever trained somewhere like there
consistently
you'll see this there's people there's
like there's like a few types of people
people who come in they just do their
thing because they got work and then
they like they're in there and then
they're out
and then there's a people who like maybe
they hang around the powerlifting rack
and it's like next you know there's like
three or four women like they kind of
meet or they come train at the same time
yeah those people who are like oh i
really want to get my squad my bench my
dead lift up like i know that group of
people is gonna leave
their gym and go to the zoo culture
correct right so if it was over there by
24 hour fitness where that same concept
i guarantee is happening just in smaller
levels or bigger levels depending on
this
they just put in those power racks like
all the twenty four zero power actually
yeah they're doing it now like you could
tell like you over the last like four
years 24-hour fitness has changed their
model drastic yeah like they try to put
turf and all their things out they try
to have like functional areas like
it's kind of how the gym has new culture
before your eyes like oh that's here now
cool they're trying to like catch up but
they they can maybe add that but they
still never have like still not the
environment yeah yeah
because because 24 for a lot of people
is like i need to get in get out because
i got work and it makes sense if that
makes sense it's amazing yeah but i knew
that like
this is the kind of spot i would open up
anywhere near these other gyms and it
would succeed because people are those
people are more serious in there are
looking for that
and also the dichotomy of like sometimes
i'll go oh i'll go to zoo culture
you should come sometime and people will
go oh no i couldn't work out there it's
probably really intense and intimidating
but conversely like actually the
experience of when you go in and people
are really
serious about fitness they're actually
excited and happy to be there and happy
to show people who don't know what
they're you know
yeah the more seriously there's some big
black dudes with their shirts out yeah
they are but they're all super nice
right they're all like you that might be
sort of that one time they're shooting
something like hey get your fat ass out
of the shot man
yeah i'm like oh [ __ ] they kicked
brendan out of it
yeah dudes right small thing and i'm
like what are you doing i'm like talking
to chappelle they're all
told bigfoot i'm like nah
[ __ ] no yeah this guy's like i've said
this for the podcast
this guy's like one of the biggest guys
in there yeah yeah i think i like i said
earlier this guy is deceptively big i'm
telling you you've been
saying you see him in real life he'd be
like what the [ __ ] it's not it's
definitely not what you see on the
internet and great genetics for strength
too because you came in like i mean
yeah um by the way i want to say this
before we continue this podcast thank
you guys for bringing me on
and like this it seems to me the
beginning of this just turning like
promoting zoo culture science
yeah because it's just been such a like
for me personally i know for these guys
all of us
it's been just a super positive way to
start the morning you know i love that
routine and that's also something that i
try to preach to other people is like
you have a
healthy positive routine surrounding
your exercise that you
enjoy and you're going to do it more
whether that's the weights or anything
else and i also wanted to ask you about
like how you
think about that like is your mindset
with like consistency and
and if you've ever like been in a rut
been depressed
and not exercised yeah so here's the
thing man the thing that is i think is
really significant
this is part of the reason why i stood
up and was like i'm going to keep my gym
open
was because you know how they're i did i
kept it open everyone goes
like not everyone like the small
minority goes why don't you just work
out at home you're such a piece of [ __ ]
like covet's killing all these people
you don't care about anyone right
right so the thing that people don't
realize and this goes on your question
is like
the gym for me my whole life has been a
place where it's like this is
this is the thing that keeps me going
not just because of the physical
activity
and like the way it makes me feel right
but mentally
and also the community like having
people you're able to see every day and
you're like that
that keeps you coming back that keeps
you happy or someone let's say
let's say like you want to learn power
lifting right and you know there's some
powerless in there and they're friendly
enough to be like to show you some stuff
or
you ask them questions they're going to
teach you now you're learning because of
the people in your in your environment
that wouldn't be the same as like just
go [ __ ] work out at home and for a
lot of people
some people need that extra like push
you know like let's say for example you
got injured
and you're working out at home and
you're just like oh [ __ ] and i'm just
injured i won't work out but if you if
your buddy knew you were going to the
gym together and he's like just come
anyway do what you can yeah you're
around right there like you have me
like-minded and even if they're
different-minded like you guys kind of
come together in a place where you're
both kind of pushing each other to
become better
so the community aspect of it is so
massive like that
people don't understand even let's say
[ __ ] like fitness goals but
maybe just you're having like a really
bad week or a bad month or a bad day
and you and you you meet your boys who
you train with and they just
they just make you feel better correct
and it's like people don't understand
that they're
like the people who don't understand are
people who don't experience it yeah so
those are the ones saying
oh you should just be at home and you're
dangerous and your cousin is like i knew
from the beginning like that just
doesn't make sense
i would have said send me your pr's
yeah like yeah how much you've been yeah
yeah the guy's probably you know yeah
like when we three get together like
it's just fun like i don't
feel like we're like yeah you can lift
and have a good time and like i
we all take it super seriously but there
is this social element to it
um that is undeniable and i think when
you talk to like psychologists about
like
what fights depression purpose community
you know self-esteem all those things
and actually as you get from
from the gym and listening to the last
podcast with with you i
it really last time bradley was on yeah
exactly
i was struck by the sincerity of like
the reasons that you kept the
the gym open it wasn't financial it
wasn't no i just didn't know or think
about like why you kept it open but
it really came across that you were like
no this is the the morally right thing
to do trying to help you anything that's
gonna help people yeah i mean bro like i
mean i've told the story a few i mean i
made a post that like
i grew up without a father that whole
thing like the gym saved my life
yeah so if i'm gonna take that away from
[ __ ] 16 17 year old me
obviously it's not me it's some other
kid who knows what he's dealing with
i knew what that'd be like to have it
taken away right and you're actively
thinking about that because there are a
lot of young people that come here like
what money like i i thought about it
again i was like are they really gonna
throw me there's no way they're gonna
throw me in jail and if they did i'm
like
worst case scenario like that's gonna be
dope on the internet
but it's like content yeah yeah bradley
martin ninja he's like why would i not
stand up to something that like
really meant something for me yeah like
but in other words it wasn't like you
for example
one extreme like you're not like a group
of anti-masters going through target
like trying to get kicked out or
something like [ __ ]
you're going this is what i believe in
that i think is right and i'm going to
take a stand against a very
powerful institution in the city los
angeles for sure
can you talk about the update on that or
no we're getting in trouble yeah
i can tell you this though this is funny
right yeah i just want to say this it's
hilarious
yeah i did get in trouble last time i
want to say this
uh they used this against them left so
okay so this is the funny thing right
like
imagine you're in a case for covid right
then and the case was you
8.77 b some penal code you kept your gym
open and we told you not to and you did
it this many times right
imagine that was your court case so now
imagine you're gathering
discovery which is like what our lawyers
and our you know prosecuting team has
against your client and they tell my
cert my to my attorneys right they're
like so here's a but it's like all these
pages of like things right and imagine
some of the
some of the content in those pages the
discovery is like well your client went
on a podcast and said he's gonna [ __ ]
sue us and this is
and what we're doing is wrong and we you
know we don't really like that we think
he's thumbing his nose he doesn't
believe and it's like i fully believe
that covet is a problem and it was a
more of a major problem obviously yeah
that doesn't mean that like
being like taken out of something that
can be so beneficial for you mentally
and physically
is not also a problem during a time when
like we don't have the cure for this
thing
why